my guest tonight is a comedian and actor
who's appeared in dozens of projects
including pitch perfect 2 and curb your
enthusiasm
he's also been called the sexiest north
bavarian dj of all time
huh and his new movie the suicide squad
is in theaters
and on hbo max on august 6. please
welcome
my very good friend i love talking to
this guy flulaborg flula welcome hello
to you conan
yes so great to see you yes you just got
a very healthy smattering of applause
thank you five peoples
yes i have to say uh first of all
um this has been a long hard pandemic
for all of us
very difficult yeah but uh i have to say
and many people complain that they have
um well they've they've not been
exercising they've been eating
incorrectly
you on the other hand look fantastic you
appear to be in incredible shape thank
you colin yes just like the marmalade
i've been pumping up the jams since
march 11
i immediately ordered one glove and five
dumbbells when i found out a pandemic
was coming wait so your first order
was not to try and get toilet paper or
lots of uh masks you ordered one mask
and
how many dumbbells one glove because the
toilet paper was sold
oh oh you got a glove improvised conan
you used a glove instead of toilet paper
i had no teepees what did you use
i used two gloves handful spread one for
clean yeah
uh old friend if i can call you that
okay uh what is it in german old friend
the idaho and uh-huh yeah um listen
uh so you've been working out constantly
during this pandemic oh very deeply yes
you know for the film suicide squad i
was told listen flula you will be
playing a hero slash villain slash who
knows so i needed to pump up all of my
bottoms all of my toppies all of my
boobies
so i just did it i went hard so uh so
which
are the parts of your body that you
really focused on your chests
uh i saw you walk in i have to say when
you walked into this theater and listen
i am uh you know a straight man okay but
i was like what the hell's happening
here
uh chess the torso the abs
your buttocks you seems like you put a
lot of work into your buttocks well i
would show you more but this is what
television not tick tock
i mean i don't know what you're talking
i am as well confused
i did one was worrying about my buttocks
so i didn't receive a photo of what is
the character looking like my character
javelin so i thought
why not make big buttocks just like that
song from destination child booty dishes
yes um it's destiny's child what's not
destination
it's not destination colon child it's
destiny's child you're certain
destination child that was never the
name of that group i'm
i'm not certain they started in europe
they were definitely we're destination
child people
turn directions okay listen um
again i'm confused by most of what you
say flula but i'm glad that you're in
terrific
i bet you could clench your buttocks
right now and fire yourself up to the
ceiling
not don i want to see it i just bet you
could yeah in syria which could happen
you know uh pandemic's difficult for all
of us the quarantining
but you fool are an extrovert i know
this about you i've
i've been on tour with you i went to
germany to berlin with you on a trip
we've had many adventures together and
i've seen you
you need people around you all the time
you love the laughter you love the
connection
how did you survive during this period
yes conan it's more important
for me to see lots of eyeballs and so
when i realized i was just going to be
in my little apartment
i decided to draw lots of faces
everywhere and i also i ordered
a photo of a sixth man of the year and
former indiana pacer deadlift shrimp
i laminated this and put this in my
shower so that while i'm luffing we can
have a conversation about sam perkins
okay so this former
nba great has been laminated into your
showers is that right deadlift shrimp
yes
okay you can slow it down just a little
bit sorry
yes of course
[Laughter]
i'm aware that during the pandemic you
tried to um
you don't have to match my mouth just
you're wearing very tight pants it's
very tight across your legs
so zero breathability yes um you i'm
aware that during this
uh quarantine and during the pandemic of
the last 14 months that you have tried
to send something to my house
but i don't know what it was and uh i'm
not sure i received it
well it's a little bit oxford um as you
know i am german all of my family is in
germany and then the borders was
bling-bling bloom no one inside you know
so
i was like who can be my family in
america i thought of course
conan yes you know we are i like to
think of myself as
as a kin to you as a friend as family
yes yes yes like that highway to heaven
like i'm the man with the beard and you
are the man
who is having the wings you know uh the
tv show highway to heaven perhaps
you're right you're not you're confused
by your own references yes i've already
forgotten uh what i just said yeah
however i was delivering every monday to
you a nice tin of lee kuhn
with all they were bribery cookies if i
want to be honest i wanted you to
receive them and then open them and see
you know it was adoption papers so that
we could you know hang hanging oh oh you
wanted me to adopt you yes
so you would send adoption papers to my
home or try to
yes very hard to get to my actual home i
know i'm an important
man and so my uh my address is a mystery
321 north mulberry avenue thanks a lot
beep it beep it no we can't afford
beeping oh yeah jeff said before the
show
no beefing yeah all that money went to
the writers
yeah i get it i get it so um that's
staying in by the way
uh listen um you sent me a so it was a
cookies cookies what kind of cookies
german tasty lab cooking yeah
i sent you 15 one every monday and they
never arrived to you i know this because
i was also the courier i don't know if
you remember i was outside waving and
then i
saw you i thought i saw you on the
security camera well i saw your face in
the porch you're just like
well i saw it no i didn't know it was
you i saw a man wearing
lederhosen and a bikini bottom and i
didn't know
if i should let him in so i didn't well
that was me number one and number two
i've saved the final uh can this is from
last april 15
and so i would like to officially i mean
thank you very much it has set it a bit
but you can
so these are what they were last march
but oh
oh these are these cookies have crumbled
yeah that's how it happens with a cookie
these looks like
very well versed in our culture probably
not safe to eat this uh you can mumble
all you want yes
okay um anyway and this is the adoption
paper that you
yeah oh this is very unprofessional oh
it's official conan o'brien would you
adopt fool of work now
check box please yes ja
now i think yes and ja are both yes
well yeah means yes yes
but do you have an option was i do i
have an option to write in now
no okay all right well let me think
about this okay
i'm gonna go through this with my
lawyers perfect and then say no
okay that's pretty much the order that's
gonna happen seems rude i purchased a
mobile for my baby room
you're gonna wanna live in a baby room
in my house well we have to begin at the
beginning have you seen the madison
billy show with adam sandley where he
starts small and then gets big
do you even know what you're saying the
madison billy show it's been many months
since i've made direct eye contact with
someone other than deadlift
while you're loofing in the shower you
know it have you been watching
no you told me that earlier oh that's
correct you
uh i'm told that during the pandemic you
started selling inventions oh
yes and uh you created something uh
called
shade dana's oh shade of danos
yeah so you know many years ago i
invented some very fun things they're
very rare and very cool and nobody
bought any but i figured you know if at
first you don't uh succeed keep doing it
over and over again
as a definition of uh sanity so i
decided to sell them once more
okay so you invented something called
shade dana's shader daniels
shade diana's what explain the name shay
dennis they are
shades fifty percent bandanas and one
hundred percent sassy
okay oh it's in your little uh [ __ ]
pouch i've saved
what whatever you call that what do you
call that it's the schlongbag
oh schlongbag yeah i'm sorry i was so
crass um this is the final uh this is
the final one so i've sold all of them
but i've been saving this one
this is a one of a kind for you this is
like if you are having the sword of
teddy roosevelt from the battle of san
juan hill
this is what this is that i you know i'm
a big teddy roosevelt fan i i
so this is a combination uh shades and
bandanas shade dana's
look at that watch out oh do you have
what's that what did you say
oh yeah hey right i'll give it to you
yeah this is fantastic i could
you know i've been i'm sporting a little
bandana lately this one i think it's
sassy this one's very sexy uh look at
this oh look at that
oh so it's oh look it's a bandana and
then
and then oh where's conan o'brien
what's a pale george clooney doing here
how did you enjoy filming the
descendants dude
of all his movies you go with the
descendants i don't know why not
of everything he's done the descendants
is what you come up sorry
how was filming the peacemaker in 1997
here clooney you come up with these
references
emmy debbie it's imdb
nobody said that that looks great
oh fantastic and if you put it on it's
like unforgiven plus
er okay you know what uh you
are this you might be onto something
here i agree with it and by that i mean
you're not
oh sarcasmos i love it she shoots you
yeah
okay what are we doing who knows um
uh well uh listen best of luck with
shade dennis thank you very much that
works
you also uh sold something called danced
on sand can you tell us what danced on
sand is yeah dance stone sands are
grains of sand that i have danced on for
eight measures of techno music and
spread around peoples with vials so they
can enjoy these grains of magic
so it's sand that you danced on for
eight measures of techno music
okay i think we brought a clip to
explain this oh yes i have an
advertisement
advertisement what nothing let's show
this
clip uh this is your new product danced
on sand which is available now yes and
action
meets a grain set of sweet intonation
danced on
sands by floor every grain is danced on
by flulaborg for at least eight measures
of music
many variety of dancers are utilized to
help to make each vial of dance dance
sans
magical dance is like lawnmower nancy
the flippy flopper the rumpelshaker
the shaky rumper the who is that
the ouch out peep pop the mule mcdoodle
and many more improve your life and your
moods when you own
danced on sans available only at
lulashop.com
uh okay um you could have shown less
examples of dances
but why i know i'm just saying you could
have cut that part in half
conan when you go to baskin robbie do
they say hey home of
maybe two flavors no they don't because
they have like how many
at least twenty okay
you know congratulations are in order
and not for your products that you're
selling okay
i don't have confidence in those at all
but the suicide squad this is a big
movie
a big movie uh that you're going to be
in and
it is very secretive you are sworn to
secrecy you can't tell anybody about the
movie
yes i was told nothing about it they
told me the name of my character so i
just started google it's javelin
javelin yeah we have a picture here of
javelin oh great
and um this is javelin right here oh
smokey jones no okay and
uh now javelin is this is um am i
correct
i don't know what his superpower is but
like all heroes he must have a special
ability
javelin what can you do can you tell us
anything about him yeah yeah he is
a former german olympic uh javelin
thrower he's very much athletic he likes
to be rude and evil
and he has a very huge
javelin yeah so in this part you
you're required to throw a javelin i'm
guessing or or use a javelin
i was not certain what i was supposed to
be doing as this javelin person so i
just started googling all of the things
of javelin
there's a band called javelin so it's
like listening to the music of javelin
that
guess what that feels unnecessary oh i
don't know you know potato patootie and
i also i started a coding in javascript
uh just for fun i made a website again
it has a form
but again i wish you had spoken to the
director he probably could have saved
you some time
why why ask just do you know okay did
you travel to
java is did you go to java no but i
googled photos of it okay
i also uh wrapped myself in javelin
which sounds like javelin and it's an
oil so i thought why not let's do it
and then also a javelina is an animal
it's a small or medium-sized mammal
that is also known as the skunk pig so i
i visited two of those and we spent some
time together
okay did you ever uh do anything
physical to prepare for this role
to the skunk pigs no no no what i meant
was
did you ever practice with an actual
javelin because i would imagine that if
the character's name is javelin you
maybe have a javelin yeah but jeff oh
sorry there's a flizzy
uh javelin's office javelin's it's a fly
right
i got it i'm pretty sure i got it no
he's here oh you got him
okay all right oh my thing is open great
theater you have here flanagan
what a wonderful place sorry my
interceptor was exposed
okay settle down yeah i'm curious did
you ever
practice with an actual javelin to
prepare for the role of javelin no it's
called acting
[Laughter]
well uh clearly you know very little bit
about the movie and you've shot the film
oh it's shot yes but i've forgotten
everything you know it's have you seen
that film with tommy tommy johnson
and he's like hey everyone what happened
oh look at my pen poop
man in black yes i got one of your
references yeah
that's a popular movie that people have
seen is it true
[Laughter]
i don't know i do want to thank you
because
um a very fond memory all of us remember
where we were when the pandemic hit when
the shutdown happened
i think i could be wrong i think you
were one of my last
guests before the lights went out and we
all went into that
14 15 month quarantine absolutely uh
conan
when it happened we had our show and
then i felt like that german
character from uh star wars hans uh hans
it's han solo and like he's like hanging
out with jabberman and he's like bye
oh and he gets frozen in carbonite yeah
and the carbon boy and then
after some months unfreeze and now this
is my first time speaking to humans
again conan
yeah so i'm like conan yeah what
conan what did i say you put an umlaut
over there you go
cunning conan cunha no it's just conan
conan sounds cool though
well that's your opinion why'd you wear
a bandana well i just did it today
i i wanted to i don't know break it up a
little bit
and as you know we wear masks but here
in the theater i like to have like a
bandanna and then
what i can do is i can just pull it up
and then look at me
yeah i'm a sassy bandit and so i've been
wearing uh
this today and i just thought it breaks
it up it's a little bit of color to have
a neckerchief
i like it i like it hey where is the
nearest saloon
because i'm a cowboy yeah
listen okay i enjoy you very much flula
also i love you as well uh
i didn't say love i said i enjoy you i
also have enjoyments of time
spent with uh yeah okay um
you're a good guy and uh i want to say
thank you
in your own native tongue maybe you
could tell me how to say that you're
feeling dang
fiend
oh well that's a song by freddie mercury
it's like in vegas singing it all the
time
i don't think that's freddie mercury
donkey shane
my darling oh wait wait wayne newton
wayne newton when you oh hello andy hi
flula how are you
oh yeah it's so great to see you how are
you doing i'm doing fine thank you
wonderful and great to see you as well
oh good yes thank you
you look good in animal prints thank you
very much this is a javelina print
so yeah call back you did do something
physical
you skinned them yeah um i know that
uh as we go out to commercial you
probably and i
plug your project you probably want to
do some kind of uh
uh german folk dance on the way out
that's probably something you would
prefer to do i would like this yes
yeah uh so why don't i begin the suicide
squad is in theaters
and on uh that's that's there's no way
that's
this part was not a german folk dance
you begin the introduction saying i'm
one of the sexiest north bavarian
uh uh male german djs hello how do you
think it could
you don't just wake up and do it yeah
you make it okay go ahead
the suicide squad is in theaters and on
hbo max
august 6th uh love love it just
everything you're doing everything
you're bringing i love hula borg
everybody conan o'brien everyone
yeah i like it's like us